qu'on a été reçu avec je pense beaucoup
d'écouté trois conseillers
ils n'ont pas menti
l'avenir éventuelle de la construction
d'un nouveau centre pénitentiaire nous
ont dit que ça c'était pas possible je
reviens pas là dessus sur le reste je
pense que on a réussi une fois de plus à
les sensibiliser sur ce qu'était
l'aménagement du territoire on n'a pas
eu d'accord extrêmement concret
en zone mais il va y avoir des
recherches nouvelles de fait je pense
sincèrement que on a été écouté des
choses qui pourront évoluer
il ya la contrainte territoire il ya des
choses qui vont être faites où ils vont
les appuyer et pour l'avenir aussi on
leur a demandé que quelques grosses
infrastructures comme par exemple la
base militaire aérienne
via son sérieux tout seul mais cela
qu'on fasse très attention qui ne la
supprime pas lorsqu on enverra les
avions